ich dachte mir es wäre ein unschuldiges
mädchen was einfach nur bisschen spaß im
supermarkt haben will dann habe ich
gesehen dass ist ein dm
dann hab ich gesehen sich wahrscheinlich
zwölf jahre alt war alles klar
321 dass meine neue begrüßung leute ab
jetzt mach ich das so oder wahlweise
auch einfach zu beginn jedes videos
jeder user seine begrüßung und jeder
youtuber sollte auch ein begrüßen haben
die zu ihm passt deswegen dachte ich mir
wie wäre es denn damit für mich okay
jetzt haben wir das geklärt wollte was
machen wir heute jetzt schon im titel
gesehen und zu diesem zwecke begeben
jetzt mal auf twitter wenn man sich
heutzutage auf twitter begibt liebe
leute dann sieht man selbstverständlich
auch solche wunderschönen bilder von
befreundeten die füße in dem moment in
dem sie nannten alltag aber leute wie
gehen auf meine seite denn hab euch in
einem tweet gebeten mir per twitter
youtube link videos zu schicken von euch
idealerweise und besonders peinlich sind
die schauen was heute an reagieren
darauf okay okay das sieht schon das
schlafzimmer video aus the way leute
bevor es mit diesem video los geht
möchte ich noch mal klarstellen dass
alles was wir heute sehen nur zum spaß
ist ja wir amüsieren uns wir machen uns
aber nicht über leute lustig sondern wir
amüsieren uns daran dass leute das leute
halt irgendwie komische sachen machen
aber wir lassen niemanden aus und wir
hätten auch in meinem nachbarn daran
okay ganz wichtig bitte das ist das ist
die jugend ist die zukunft ich meine an
dem was ihr in diesem video macht gibt
es überhaupt nichts zu kritisieren das
ist eine absolut normale beschäftigung
ist eine ganze mahlzeit beschäftigung im
jahre 2017 schüler machen nicht mehr
hausaufgaben lernen nicht mehr sondern
laden videos auf twitter hoch wo sie
durchgehend dämmen und danach
wahrscheinlich eine gehirnerschütterung
haben das sieht schon sehr speziell aus
hier
die züge die zukunft deutschlands ist
rose ein teil der jugend sitzt vor einer
mit bildern behängen warnt und reagiert
auf videos die andere aufgenommen haben
indem sie entweder auf below ausrutschen
oder durchgehen denn was soll diesem
land was du diese welt noch passieren
wisst ihr was ich brauch erst mal so
einen fetten basecap ein und zwar was
haben wir hier was sehen wir im ersten
frame nix sehen gar nix ok wo hält sich
diese versuchen auch ich versuche gerade
dieses bild räumlich einzuordnen ist es
blau da unten im himmel wo zur hölle ist
das beste was heute schreibt genau jetzt
mal in die kommentare
ohne das video weiter zuschauen was
glaubt ihr an welcher stelle hält sich
diese person gerade auf leer ist das
glaube ich an welcher stelle hat sich
lehrer auf in diesem video für mich
sieht aus als wird da irgend eine
rolltreppe durchs bild fahren
dieses video aus heißen diese videos auf
youtube immer mit 40 millionen klicks
für leute was tolles machen dass leute
hier ist pieper aus um 2017 erste
edition um menschen einen
identifizierbaren orten sitzen und nicht
runter kommt was haben wir hier paul
philipp okay ein mensch ein mensch läuft
ein mensch läuft sich ein
einkaufszentrum
was keiner groß passieren oder
einzukaufen
nein nein nein nein
ich hab's garten leute ich dachte mir es
werden unschuldige kleines mädchen ist
unschuldiges mädchen marbella ich dachte
mir es werden unschuldige stylus mädchen
was einfach ein bisschen spaß im
supermarkt haben will dann hab ich
gesehen ist es ein dm
dann hab ich gesehen sie ist
wahrscheinlich zwölf jahre alt war alles
klar
check24 leute das war wirklich hart aber
werden wir neues video von elementen und
luca kommt drin vor
das könnt ihr diese video von luca
passieren
ja wie gesagt im alter wenn wir dieses
video sieht man wirklich den glauben an
die menschheit ist einfach so etwas
macht was machst du da was was erhofft
sich davon dass er eine massive beton
sollte schlägt ich vermute mal als ich
gerade in video über irgendwas aufgeregt
aber gesetzlich so als würde jetzt die
solche vögel über heute so viel wie die
von max von feli wesen das könnte unter
umständen einer von maxis berühmten
musicals sein wenn er und musik steht
und es ist musik des musicals
allein wenn max so schon schotten
rechtmäßig steht dann wisst ihr dass
gleich irgendwas selbst was passieren
wird
[Musik]
ein weiteres wertvolles
ausstellungsstück in unserer pipeline
aus 5m kinetischen ein junger mensch
namens maximilian der stadtwerke laut
meili
im hintergrund laufen lässt mit seinen
banken gestapelt ich bin ich bin einfach
ich bin auch stolz leute wieder vor
stolz gibt diese momente im leben da ist
man einfach stolz auf seine familie weil
die wirklich was erreicht hat steht ihr
weil die wirklich der welt gezeigt haben
was sie drauf haben okay leute neues
video li na ja das könnte eventuell
passieren ein lustiger mensch der gerade
aus jerusalem nach deutschland gelaufen
ist habe sich am wasser eines pools ich
hoffe doch mal rein
was soll ich sagen auf die platte das
ist wie sehr würde ich auf ein piepsen
bietet draufklicken wenn das auf top
level wieder brauche ich mir nicht sagen
es ist alles gesagt wurde okay leute
nächstes video von lina jetzt hat sie
sich gedacht ja dafür wird mich
wahrscheinlich roten für das video
gerade eben und hat im gegenzug mal
richtig fette geschütze aufgefahren ja
als meine erste videos comstar sprache
wir haben wir haben kein oder schlecht
läuft ist das bitter wir haben kein
equipment dabei weihnachtsfeiertage mit
mit familie und so am türken ja was hast
du so schön bekommen zu weihnachten
ich habe zu weihnachten bekommen
eigentlich doch mal die socken bekommen
[Musik]
wir können bei diesem fall will sich
stoppen ja wunderbar was bekommst zu
weihnachten socken und hat ich bin so
froh dass das ist jetzt nicht der
dezember 2013 ist ich bin so froh
begleichen mit dem weil wahrscheinlich
ist feldkamp selbst oder welche welches
kulabas weg
sie kommen leute schätzt man den
kommentaren